[Music]
on this saturday night federal election
final push
justin trudeau's busy seven-stop day in
ontario where the liberals have cut ties
with a toronto candidate
is the conservative campaign slowing
down as aaron o'toole still refuses to
say how many candidates are vaccinated
we still don't know who's vaccinated in
your party plus the ndp's jug meat singh
sets his sights on tory held ridings
hard hit by cobit 19. people should be
angry at the conservative premiers they
did a horrible job and how unemployment
in newfoundland and labrador could rock
the vote
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight nitu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
election day in canada is now just two
days away federal party leaders are
pounding the pavement this weekend
making their final pitch to voters
liberal leader justin trudeau was busy
with seven stops focusing his efforts in
ontario his main rival conservative
leader aaron o'toole is also there
taking a more measured approach with
some of the tightest riding races in the
country there is much to be gained or
lost in vote rich ontario abigail beeman
is with the liberal campaign
so in the coming two days
i need you to go flat out just like i
will
justin trudeau is going flat out in the
final stretch seven stops saturday
across southern ontario in extremely
tight races seats he wants to win and
ones he's trying to save still quite a
bit of uncertainty and there's a lot of
voter volatility at this point and so it
really counts it's a big deal to go out
and try to flip those ridings
this was his third visit to richmond
hill a riding won by just over 200 votes
in 2019 among the tightest races in the
country it makes you anxious that he
needs to come here three times
no i actually see that as a privilege
and i see as an opportunity for me i
think you've got to give the nod today
to the conservative and i'll tell you
why
because although the ndp
candidate only got nine percent of the
vote
i think they're going to do better for
that reason trudeau's messaging against
vote splitting has been ramping up
despite what the ndp likes to say
the choice
is between a conservative or a liberal
government right now
and it does make a difference to
canadians whether we have or not a
progressive government
the liberals are having a strong final
week but a blow saturday when they
announced they kicked out candidate
kevin vuong in the 11th hour for a
dropped sexual assault charge they say
they learned about from the toronto star
it is a
difficult but important thing to do
because it's the right thing to do after
raj sani that's the second liberal
candidate dropped too late in the race
to replace meaning two lost liberal
seats the liberals are in the worst case
scenario in these ridings or at least
the other parties have a shot at winning
them he's trying to move to that 170
and the margins are not clear and are
small most ridings the liberal campaign
visited saturday are ones they've been
in before conservatives have visited two
i asked trudeau for his insights as to
why he's spending so much time in
southern ontario in the final days but
he stuck to his stump speech talking
points about a choice for canadians in
his answers abigail beeman global news
new market ontario
i'm mike liquiteur with the conservative
campaign in cambridge ontario where the
pace is decidedly different from the
liberals erin o'toole spent the night
just steps away from canada's largest
year-round farmers market a perfect
place to meet voters the conservative
leader didn't do that
i ran by the farmers market this
this morning in the final sprint to
election day erin o'toole's tour seems
to be taking a jog his schedule isn't
overloaded with whistle stops and
rallies in southwestern ontario leading
some to wonder if the former member of
canada's air force is on autopilot but
this conservative strategist doesn't see
it that way to be fair to mr o'toole
it's important to recognize when you
know the puck was dropped on this game
uh on the 15th of august there was no
sense that he would be in it we're down
to the last minutes uh and he's still in
the game congratulations mr white man
following an event in cambridge natalie
fonseca tried to get o'toole's attention
to talk to him about indigenous issues
but the conservative leader didn't even
break his stride he wants to come to my
city to take photos
of how wonderful he's doing but he
doesn't want to ask answer any questions
is that fair thank you guys o'toole's
focus in recent days has been on vote
splitting warning canadians a vote for
anyone but the conservatives will hand
the liberals another win
however he continues to face questions
about whether or not all conservative
candidates are fully vaccinated we have
a rule that everyone that's campaigning
for us candidates people going door to
door have to use vaccines
and if someone is not fully vaccinated
they must use a daily rapid test
and follow all the public health
guidance in the provinces it's an issue
that continues to trip up the
conservative leader as he tries to lock
in votes
nithu
michaela couture in cambridge ontario
for us tonight thanks mike
today ndp leader jagmeet singh is
setting his sights on two of canada's
covet 19 hot spots campaigning in
alberta and saskatchewan right now they
are by far the provinces with the
highest rate of active cases singh is
pointing the finger at their provincial
governments and blaming trudeau too
singh is hoping disgruntled moderate
conservatives will take a left turn on
monday robin gill is following the ndp
campaign robin
litu the ndp leader turned his attacks
on the provincial premiers for their
handling of the pandemic the prairies
have become the center now of a
political battle health care workers you
are amazing judgment singh started his
day in saskatoon an opportunity to take
advantage of a province where voters can
go back and forth between the
conservatives and new democrats alberta
is also the land of this ndp tory switch
both provinces are held by conservatives
provincially singh was quick to
reprimand the premiers for dismissing
restrictions and allowing coven 19 cases
to rise to the highest counts in canada
i absolutely condemn the the
conservative premier's horrible
leadership but i also condemn mr
trudeau's horrible leadership the fact
that he called a pandemic or called an
election in a pandemic that no one
wanted and to this day he can't even
explain why he called it at no point did
he attack the federal conservative
leader aaron o'toole again targeting
political enemy number one justin
trudeau and his handling of the pandemic
we would have put in place a paid sickly
program that worked right away right in
the beginning so that people wouldn't
have to go to work sick we would
implemented vaccine passwords right away
so people would have that avenue to show
proof of vaccination and encourage more
people to get vaccinated we would have
done a lot better it's a strategy to
keep votes away from the liberals and
hang on to new democrat support
the ndp has seen a surge in support in
both alberta and saskatchewan but in
alberta it's interesting in 2019 that
support was at 12 percent today it's 22.
niku robin gill in saskatoon for us
tonight thanks robin
green party leader annemie paul brought
her campaign to british columbia today
where the party held its two remaining
seats when parliament was dissolved the
greens popularity has slipped
significantly since the 2019 election
and there's no guarantee it will hang on
to both ridings once the votes are
tallied global bc's richard zusman joins
us from victoria where paul made one of
her final pitches to voters richard
british columbia more specifically
vancouver island has long been fertile
ground for greens the question is what
took anime pole so long to visit the
province this trip on saturday her only
one of the campaign to victoria
a hope is that she will be able to flip
the party's fortunes in 2015 the party
won more than 8 percent of the vote
province-wide and it led to one seat
elizabeth mays in 2019 they added
another seat paul manley and nanaimo
lady smith and over 12 percent of the
vote well this time they're polling at
around 6 percent and have a lot of
ridings where they aren't even running
candidates
i can't speak for mr weaver i
haven't had the opportunity
to speak with him you know since his
decision i've said that i respect him
but i respectfully disagree with him on
this
um
i don't know what else to say about this
i've been asked that question a lot i i
understand that he is uh well known but
of course
the people who put together our climate
plan our green future
are also incredibly well known other
than may andrew weaver is likely the
best known green in british columbia the
former provincial leader though this
time is supporting justin trudeau and
the liberals he's been campaigning with
them across british columbia when paul
was asked about it saturday she says
there are people working on the green
climate plan who worked with weaver and
that ultimately the liberals plan is
snake oil we'll see if this last minute
visit has any impact on how british
colombians vote on monday richard zusman
global national victoria
the leader of the bloc quebecois is
looking to attract votes in this final
weekend of the campaign
each second
of those two days
will be given to getting the best the
best possible results
party leader eve francois blanchette is
hitting the pavement in quebec city
support for the block is up many say
because of a response from blochette
during the english language debate when
he was asked about two bills that have
been referred to as discriminatory
blochette is also vowing to make the
next parliament work as his party fights
for seats possibly keeping the next
government to a minority
so what should canadians watch for after
polls close on monday our ottawa bureau
chief mercedes stevenson is joining us
now to discuss mercedes neither thanks
obviously canadians wondering what's
going to happen tomorrow and normally in
a federal election i've covered several
in the last 10 years we have a sense of
where this might come out and we really
don't know so start watching in atlantic
canada if that doesn't turn completely
liberal red the liberals are in trouble
doesn't mean they couldn't still pull
off a minority but a majority which we
already know is a remote chance will be
down the tubes at that point we're also
going to be looking at what does support
look like for the ndp in the people's
party of canada those are the two
potential political wild cards either
one could cause the opposite side to
lose or win the ndp could take votes as
you heard an abigail story away from the
liberals and the ppc could take votes
away from the conservatives those could
create vote splits where a party that
normally would not win a riding is able
to take the day we'll be looking to see
as we go across the gta and quebec as
well and the lower mainland right here
in vancouver to see how things are
starting to play out and mercedes what
will the ballot question be and what
some are calling a campaign about
nothing well i
think that that's a great question and
it's one that we really don't have the
answer to neither
you know this has been the campaign
about nothing the seinfeld election
afghanistan really was something that
dominated the campaign early on we've
talked about affordability we've talked
about covet 19 and we've talked about
leadership but what it'll really come
down to is a lot of emotion and it will
also come down
to a campaign where whether people
decide
in a referendum they want to keep justin
trudeau on as the prime minister or if
they're ready for change aaron o'toole
has over performed what his critics
expected but that doesn't necessarily
mean that he's going to be able to win
on monday night but we'll be keeping a
close eye on that it will be fascinating
all around our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson thanks mercedes
and mercedes will have much more
tomorrow on the west block right here on
global
and mercedes will join global nationals
donna friesen for our extensive coverage
on election night monday right here on
global television as well as on history
global news radio and various online
platforms including globalnews.ca
i'm ross lord and saint john's
newfoundland and labrador some pandemic
restrictions have eased but there's
tension here over the sorry state of the
province's finances and what a green
economy will mean to the offshore oil
and gas industry that story coming up on
global national
unemployment has been on the rise in
newfoundland and labrador since the
start of the pandemic and without the
ability to put groceries on the table
the question is being asked will
frustrated residents put the liberals
themselves out of a job come voting day
as ross lord reports in a place
nicknamed the rock tens of thousands of
people now find themselves in a hard
place
after 11 years as an offshore worker
trent taylor has never been more
grateful to have a job i'm
one of the fortunate ones actually who
fortunate to keep the job through all
this
so
count my blessings i guess considering
how the industry is he's a control
systems operator on this vessel that's
helped produce
425 million barrels of oil from the
terra nova field when the pandemic
undermined an oil market that was
already shaky hundreds of jobs on the
ship were lost i'm in a hard spot amanda
young says since she was laid off from
her job as a taranova cook last october
she's been living on savings and small
loans she says they've been depleted you
gotta pay a mortgage
and your bills and you still can't fit a
car and you still can't fit groceries in
so i mean this is what we're looking at
right now newfoundland and labrador
leads the country in unemployment at
almost 12 percent well above the
national average of 7.9 and the
province's finances are grim all around
at 14 billion dollars the province's net
debt is also by far the worst in canada
per capita partly because of the oil
downturn and from rampant spending on
health care for its aging population
the province that begged the prime
minister for help paying its bills after
the pandemic hit is now planning what it
calls the big reset to keep from
drowning in debt there are tough
questions about the province's offshore
oil and gas industry like what the shift
to a green economy will mean to these
offshore supply vessels and whether that
shift will eliminate reliable paychecks
how are you familiar face famous oregon
how's it going natural resources
minister seamus o'regan who's running
for reelection in newfoundland says the
answer is retraining we need them
they are the ones who will lower
emissions it is complex stuff this isn't
easy
regan says retraining is a big part of a
320 million dollar aid package already
given to the industry
but one year later how that money
trickles down to workers is still
unclear i haven't heard anything on what
we're switching to and what training is
available for us young and trent taylor
both suggest they won't vote for any
party that aggressively promotes a green
agenda it definitely influences where
i'm going and where my decision is going
to be come election time if other
offshore workers walk away from the
liberals it could complicate the party's
efforts to keep a grip on atlantic
canada
ross lord global news st johns
newfoundland and labrador
still ahead why trump supporters went to
rally at the scene of the capitol hill
riot
you're watching global national
[Music]
as we talk about the canadian election
donald trump is still trying to
challenge the results of the american
vote more than 10 months ago and this
weekend one of the most defining moments
of the trump presidency is back in the
spotlight with police keeping watch over
demonstrators who are demanding justice
for those prosecuted after the january
6th attack on capitol hill jennifer
johnson reports
about 200 demonstrators much fewer than
expected descended on capitol hill in
support of rioters arrested after the
january 6 attack but it was a completely
different scene than the violent
storming of the capitol eight months ago
still many are angry but those people
who came in that capitol building
instead of calling them terrorists why
don't you find out why they breached the
capitol why they were so desperate
to cling on to donald trump
and even former president donald trump
called those arrested after attacking
the capital political prisoners we
believe that the reason these people are
being persecuted isn't because of what
they did but because of what they
believe and that's wrong with persistent
lies still circulating the election was
stolen from trump police were prepared
the capital was barricaded behind a two
meter high steel fence internet chatter
warned of possible violence every
available officer from d.c maryland and
virginia were here what happened on
january 6 can't happen again and we're
really proud to be here today standing
shoulder to shoulder on friday trump
sent another letter to georgia's
secretary of state demanding he declare
trump actually won the election trump
supporters still believe biden is not
the legal president it was all fraud
anything done under fraud
is fraudulent and
it should be thrown out since the 2020
election the capitol has become a magnet
for attempted violence including a
day-long bomb threat and standoff last
month many lawmakers hope as the trump
years fade away so will the protests
jennifer johnson global news washington
next the priorities young canadians are
taking to the polls
since canada's 2019 election interest in
politics has gone up by 10 percent among
youth according to an abacus data study
between the pandemic racial injustices
and the climate crisis major issues in
the past two years have affected young
lives and as olivia o'malley explains
canada's youngest voters could make or
break this election if they show up to
the polls
the sky is the limit for post secondary
students preparing for their future a
future that canada's youngest voters are
considering during this federal election
what's really pressing right now is like
climate solutions and
just in terms of like the trudeau
government
considering what they've done
it seems like they could do more i chose
the green party environment is the top
priority for me according to ipsos most
younger voters remain more socially
progressive than older voters but
millennials are now approaching life
events that can change priorities one of
the key issues that they're looking at
is climate change so that's not
any different from what we've measured
in the past but for them it's also about
affordability cost of living i have a
very good job very stable have a family
and yet it's
i don't know if i'll ever be able to buy
a house the soon-to-be father of two
says he voted for the ndp because the
party's platform aligns with the future
he wants for his family
yo bro who got you smiling like that
like ndp leader jug meat singh is the
only federal leader creating videos that
often go viral on tick-tock
experts say his social media fluency is
a valuable tool for reach and
approachability drug meeting has easily
the strongest tick-tock presence which
does have a huge hugely disproportionate
share of
of young people participating
millennials and gen zeds make up the
biggest voting block in this election
about 40 percent of the voting
population but turnout has not
historically been the younger
generation's strong suit in the past two
federal elections voters aged 18 to 34
have shown up the least hovering just
above 50 percent they're no more cynical
they're just as interested they just
have a different approach to political
participation and elections canada not
running on campus voting due to the
pandemic could limit student votes but
if a surge of younger voters commit they
could decide writings or the entire
election olivia o'malley global news
montreal
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm nitu garcia tonight
your canada is the waterfront in pikto
nova scotia so serene please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]